Speaker 1: All right, welcome, everybody. It's
great to be back. A lot of good things to talk
about, some not so good. We're going to be going
over so much took place, indictment's rallies,
so many different things during our vacation.
But where I want to start is with the latest on
covid cases and deaths. We're going to do a deeper
dove tomorrow about what's going on on a state by
state basis. But what is increasingly happening is
that this pandemic is becoming essentially a red
state, blue state pandemic. We now have different
enough vaccination rates in states like Hawaii,
Vermont, Massachusetts and others compared to
places like Mississippi and particular Alabama,
Arkansas, that this Delta variant is wreaking
drastically different levels of havoc
in the more vaccinated states versus in the less
vaccinated states. And the difference is only
going to grow due to the level of contagion of
this Delta variant believed to be reproducing and
are not somewhere between five and eight. The
Delta variant, which is significantly more
contagious than the sort of original strain of
the coronavirus believed to be somewhere in the,
you know, two to four, two and a half to three and
a half range. And this is not merely a curiosity,
it's actually having a real impact. And
there's a new Associated Press report
that nearly all covid deaths are now among the
unvaccinated. The numbers are just incredible.
The Associated Press writing, nearly all covid
deaths in the U.S. are now in people who aren't
vaccinated. A staggering demonstration of how
effective the shots have been and an indication
that deaths per day now under 300 could be
practically zero if everyone eligible got the
vaccine. An Associated Press analysis of available
government data from May shows that breakthrough
infections and fully vaccinated people accounted
for fewer than twelve hundred of more than
one hundred and 7000 hospitalizations. So that
means of those hospitalized, one point one percent
were vaccinated compared to ninety eight point
nine percent of hospitalizations being in those
who were not vaccinated. And then further, only
about 150 of the more than 18000 covid deaths
in May were in fully vaccinated people. That
translates to about zero point eight percent
or five deaths per day. On average, only about
45 states report breakthrough infections. Some
are more aggressive than others in looking for
such cases. So the data probably understates such
infection. So there's a few important details here
to consider. One is at this point, there's just no
question whatsoever about the level of protection
that the vaccines provide, including against
the Delta variant. Some might say, well, you
could get sick anyway and you could end up in
the hospital and you could die. And of course,
that's true. But often the people saying that
are those who don't want to get vaccinated,
seemingly failing to understand that by they
themselves getting vaccinated, they become less
likely to pass on any of these variants to someone
who has been vaccinated but might be in the eight
or so percent that has not developed antibodies.
Now, one other thing, and we're going to look
into this in more detail tomorrow. There's a
I don't even know about a report. There's
there's we'll call it a report. It's not
it's not a study. But there is a news report
out of Israel, a highly vaccinated country,
that they believe there may only be 64 percent
protection against the Delta variant for the
Pfizer vaccine. Remember that Israel started
vaccinating very early exclusively with the
Phizer vaccine, or at least initially exclusively
with the Fizer vaccine. And of course, when you
see that and you say, oh, it was 92 percent, only
64 percent effective against the Delta variant,
some good epidemiologists, including Dr. Ashish
Jha, who we had on the show a couple of weeks ago,
and others have said they as of now are unsure
about that 64 percent number and sort of a two two
pronged response. One, we don't really know that
that's the number. And it sounds suspiciously low.
It's probably higher than that, but lower than 92
percent. But more importantly, even though cases
have started to tick back up in Israel as the
Delta variant spreads, hospitalizations for now
are at least not up. And that would be the
vaccine doing its job, which is preventing
serious illness, preventing hospitalization
and ultimately preventing death. So
regardless of your view as to the seriousness of
that variant, it still makes sense to just go and
get vaccinated, because not only do you. Yourself,
you also protect people that may be vaccinated,
but either immunocompromised or just in that
that, you know, it's on a bell curve, antibody
development is on a bell curve and not everybody
develops those antibodies. The one other thing
there are immediately there are always conspiracy
theorists and I've seen floating around, oh,
the people who were vaccinated and died
died from the vaccine. And of course,
there's no evidence of that whatsoever. The
vast majority of those folks were vaccinated,
you know, months, months before in many cases
that there's no evidence of that. But remember
that that's how conspiracy ism works. And it
should be no surprise that that's the way that
some people are going to react. I got an email
from an E.R. doctor who works in a less vaccinated
red state and he said they are regularly seeing at
their hospital that just like the national data,
almost everybody who's being hospitalized and even
more so, almost everybody who's dying of the virus
was not vaccinated. And he said, you know, I
understand that it's easy not to feel sympathy for
some of these folks in some sense. I mean, listen,
they didn't get vaccinated. They could have they
got sick then they died. But he had a different
take, which I think is reasonably empathetic,
which is they fell for disinformation. And in a
sense, we should we should sympathize with that.
They didn't get vaccinated because they became
convinced of things that weren't true. They were
victimized by purveyors of of disinformation. And
societally, there is some responsibility to that.
I get that on the bonus show today. I'm going to
tell the story from last week from my trip of a
Lyft driver who told me he wasn't getting
vaccinated because his mom became magnetic
after getting the second dose. So that'll be on
today's bonus show. But stunning, stunning stuff.